I'm terrified I'm looking to really
learn what it's all about
this is kind of all I know we are
introducing Bollywood dance to Americans
who have never experienced volley way
before all up the face tons and tons of
energy and drama I don't care about
anything I mean if you've never done
this before I don't want to see it on
your face I want your face to be like I
got this so hope I'm okay so I expect
people to come in with a fair amount of
trepidation usually people are a little
bit nervous to try it because it looks
so dramatic and big and exciting and
sometimes cheesy as soon as we jump into
it I think with me screaming at you like
them they'll forget all about it and
just be able to jump in and and learn
the moves good so that's your basic and
that's your step touches okay thumb
index middle right maybe it was so many
emotions of like sexy face happy face
sexy face serious sexy happy sexy happy
it was overall sexy
angry like sexy goes before every other
at the gift okay so now we're gonna have
my dancers my beautiful professional
dancers come out in their costumes and
we're going to show the new dancer is
exactly what the combos still look like
with costumes
so are you ready to do it like that
let's get you in your costumes put some
Mindy's on you get some ankle bells on
the girl some crystals on the boys come
on let's go it's a different type of
exercise I think just fun for anyone
which thinks they can't dance just do
Bollywood it's just bouncing and just
fun out of this lot of this
there's so much fun it was a blast
that's so much fun
oh my god I think it takes a different
type of control yeah I'm taking this to
the club Friday night and see how I fare
it was intense though I feel like even
if you don't really get the movement as
long as you have the energy and it just
bouncing all over the place you'll get
back you know you can kind of just I
feel like we could maybe be in the
background of some Bollywood movie I
swear
do this and be like yeah we do this
trailer